police in Vancouver are looking for
people this is true
police in Vancouver are actually looking
for people to drink alcohol so they can
train their recruits to do sobriety
tests yes this is a real thing
this is nuts the Vancouver Police are
asking for volunteers to get drunk
isn't that crazy Andy Andy
[Music]
that's stupid that's just stupid Andy
and anyway they're looking for Canadian
citizens only
[Music]
turns out they only want Canadian
citizens I know Andy yeah anyway as I
was saying the program is drawing
controversy because I Andrew Richter hi
Andrew Richter swear to bear true
allegiance to Her Majesty Queen
Elizabeth and faithfully female might
fulfil my duties as a Canadian citizen
all right congratulations a year your
Canadian
[Applause]
Andy this is idiotic none of this makes
any sense you can get the same alcohol
right here in Burbank California Andy
authorities say Richter is driving over
100 miles an hour and headed toward
Delray liquor store those destroyers are
incredibly idiotic he couldn't wait to
get drunk
you